[موسيقى]
دبابات ابراج في طريقها لاوكرانيا بعد حل
الخلاف بين واشنطن وبرلين والكريملين
يتوعد
قاد التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت يحرك
المياه الراكده ويوجه اتهاما للمدعي العام
وثلاثه خضار
[موسيقى]
بعد بيض وترامب مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكيه يضبط وثائق سريه في منزل مايكل
وتويتر تواجه دعوتين قضائيتين في سان فرست
سان فرانسيسكو بسبب عدم دفع ايجار المقر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نقلت صحيفه ور ستريت جورنال عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان الولايات
المتحده تتجه لارسال الدبابات ابرامز الى
اوكرانيا الصحيفه الامريكيه اكدت ان
الاعلان عن ارسال الدبابات عبرنس الى
اوكرانيا سيكون هذا الاسبوع رغم تصريحات
الامريكيه سابقه تحدثت عن مشاكل قد وجوهها
اوكرانيا بالتعامل مع الدبابات بالصيانه
والتشغيل الى ذلك اكدت صحيفه درج فيجل
الالمانيه انا برلين سترسل 10 دبابات لي
واخواتي الى اوكرانيا لكن موعد الوصول غير
محدد كما ستسمح للدول التي تملكها كافو
لندن بارسالها الى اخرى
نقلت ان شغلت سيعلن ارسال الدبابات ليوباد
الى اوكرانيا غدا امام البرلمان الالماني
وفي اول تعليق لها الرئاسه الاخرانيه
تعتبر ارسالا مئات الدبابات الكاف دفعه
للديمقراطيه
المتحدث
اوكرانيا قال انه واشنطن صوت واصل تلبيه
احتياجتك لمواجهه روسيا كما اشار الى ان
دبابات ابرامز معقده وتحتاج الى صيانه
دوريه والى تدريب المكثف وصعب
تزويد القران
على هذه الاسلحه سنعمل على تزويد اوكرانيا
بكافه احتياجاتها اللوجستيه انظمه
الدبابات انظمه معقده ويصعب صيانتها
وعندما ناكد منح اوكرانيا الدعم العسكريه
اللازم سنعلن ذلك كما انه ليس من المفيد
ان نمنح اوكرانيا اسلحه وانظمه لا تستطيع
صيانتها سنعمل على احصاء اوكرانيا
اثر فعال في ميدان المعركه نحن واضحون
باجراء نقاشات مع اوكرانيا بشان متطلباتها
الدفاعيه قصيره وطويله الامل
الاتحاد المسيحي الديمقراطيه ينضم الينا
سيد مصطفى اهلا بكم معنا بحال صدقه سال
تقارير صحفيه بانه غدا
سيسمح بتصدير هذه بث الى اوكرانيا
لماذا يكون الفوز غير رايهم ما الذي جعله
يسمح بذلك بعد كل هذا الرفض خلال سنه
كامله
مساء الخير عليكم
من قبلنا حزب الاتحاد وايضا من قبل العديد
من الاطراف والحلفاء والشركاء واذا الموقف
بولندا الجري الذي كان اليوم تقريبا هو
تقريبا شبه تهديد بانه سوف تريد ان تساعد
لكن لو ارسلت بولندا من غير موافقه
المانيا كانت هذه ايضا يعني اللي ضرر جدا
كبير الاسمر نعتقد امراض السيد الى يوم
الغد حتى لا يستطيع يعني الاذى والضرر
الذي لحقه بالسمع الالمانيه عليه ان يصلح
هذا يوم غد وايضا يكون جدا واضح وصريح
لانه تقريبا هذا يضيع العديد من الكثير من
الوقت لهذه المماطله كان من البدايه عليه
ايضا من المؤتمر مش انا في الاسبوع الماضي
ان يكون لهم موقف واضح منها بهذا الملف
وين يكون همم تم حسمه لانه اوكرانيا تريد
لا تريد ايضا هجمات على رؤوسنا فقط تريد
ايضا مصطفى
الدبابات لاوكرانيا همم يعني اليس معه حق
ان يتخوف من هذا الامر
وهولندا وهو باقي الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
نحن جميعا وشركاه في هذه المسؤول يجب ان
لا يكون هناك اتخاذ قرارات منفرده الجميع
هنا في السراء والضراء لماذا المانيا فقط
جاهزه لاعطاء ايضا فقط او قاتل ايام
الجيده اعطاء الاموال واعطى كل شيء ولكن
عندما يحتاج بعض البلدان الدفاع عن
سيادتها وحدتها نتملص من هذا من هذه
المسؤوليه اعتقد كان من السيد ان يكون له
جدا قرار حاسم منذ البدايه حتى منذ بدايه
الحرب قبل تقريبا سنه من الان- كان يريد
ارسال تقريبا قوه عسكريه 500 خذيه عسكريه
او اكثر همم ماذا يعمل العسكري وتم احتلال
تقريبا العديد من اجزائها
اذا تم اتخاذه هو غدا هل هو مرتبط ايضا
بموضوع ارسال دبابات ابرا برنس الامريكيه
الى اوكرانيا هل كان ينتظر هذه الخطوه من
الامريكيين حتى يقوم هو بهذه الخطوه
المماثله
هذا كان فقط عباره عن مبرر هو يريد ان
يعني يرمي الكره في ملعب الامريكان حتى
انه يقول اذا ارسلهم نحن سوف نرسل بما انه
دبابات ابرازيه تقريبا اكثر تعقيدا من
اليوبار ليوبارديا سليبرتس باي اثنين هي
اسم من ناحيه الصيانه وايضا من ناحيه
الوقود وان ايضا من ناحيه التدريبات
اللوجستيكيه وايضا التقنيه ايضا بامكان
المانيا
لكن هذا عباره عن فقط يريد ان يضع
المسؤوليه عند الامريكان ولا هو يريد ان
يتحمل مسؤوليه وحده لكن الحرب هي هنا
موجوده للاسف اليوم فقط قد سمعه او اطلاق
الرصاصه هذه الحرب
غدا هل يكون قد حافظ على وحده الموقف
الاوروبي من هذه الحرب
امامه الكثير لتصحيح السيدز مثل ماذكار
قبل قليل واذا مثل ما ذكرها السيد
فريدريشماس قال عليه ان يصلح ما ادى به
بضرر لسمعه الالمانيه نحن تقريبا الان
منعزلين في اتخاذ قراراتنا المانيا ليس هي
المانيا السابق هناك تناقض هناك نفاق جدا
كبير بالسياسه الالمانيه للاسف وعلينا
تصحيح هذا المساء
كيف سيترقها
على حسب المعارضه اولا وحزب شغل وايضا
المواطن الالماني
علينا ان ناخذ الموضوع هو كالسياسيا
المواطن الالماني نعم يريد ايضا الحريه
والديمقراطيه يريد ان يحمي اوروبا كان ان
يكون موقف واضح للسيد منذر البدايه لكن هو
الان اصبح مجبورا وامامر الواقع لكن للاسف
لم يكن له قرار واضح منذ البدايه وهذه
نقطه تحتسب عليه شكرا
الديمقراطيه على المشاركه معنا في اخبار
الساعه
حملت اقالات واستقالات تعصف في اوكرانيا
طالت عددا من المسؤولين الاخرين على خلفيه
فضائح فساد في حكومه الرئيس
مكتبي في ذات الوقت اكد مكتب المدعي العام
لاوكرانيا اقاله اوليكس سي مونيكو منصب
نائب المدعي العام بناء على طلبه والى
جانب اعلان الحكومه الاوكرانيه
في قضيه فساد قدم نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
شراء الموارد الغذائيه للوحدات العسكريه
الاكرانيه اذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
لاوكرانيه قد يضع بلاده امام اسوء
السيناريوهات مثلا وفق مراقبين فانا ظهور
ملفات فساد في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
والاقالات والاستقالات التي طالت مسؤولين
كبار يمكن ان يضعف حماه الغرب في دعم
الجيش شكرا ايه في المرحله المقبله خصوصا
وانزال بانه لن يتم التغاضي عن الفساد
الذي يمثل مشكله مزمنه في البلاد وتعهد
باتخاذ قرارات رئيسيه بشان القضاء عليها
هذا الاسبوع في خطوه لاستماله الغرب في
مواصله دعم كاف بالسلاح
قراراتهم تتعلق بشؤون الموظفين بعضها صدر
اليوم والبعض الاخر سيستر غدا بشان
المسؤولين في الوزارات من مختلف في
المستويات
وهياكل الحكومه المركزيه وكذلك في المناطق
وفي نظام انفاذ القانون
اذا مشاهدينا هناك اخبار عاجله وردت قبل
قليل على شاشه العربيه قذفت امريكيه ستلقم
100 من المتفجرات على اهداف في صحراء
النقب ضمن التدريب مع اسرائيل ايضا بان
هناك تدريب اسرائيلي امريكي سيقصف اهداف
تحاكي مواقع النوويه ايرانيه ايضا اا كان
هناك اخبار عاجله ولكنها كانت خاصه
باوكرانيا وهي الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول لا
نملك معلومات حتى الان بشان قضايا الفساد
والاقالات في اوكرانيا
الامريكيه للاسلحه سبته حرب اوكرانيا وفي
حال خروج الولايات المتحده حربا قد تنفذ
ذخيره خلال اسبوع حيث كشف تقرير جديد
لصحيفه ان الحرب في اوكرانيا كشفت مشاكل
كبيره في صناعه الاسلحه الامريكيه موضحا
ان تلك المشاكل قد تعوف قدره الجيش الامري
على خوض حرب طويله الامد ضد الصين وان
مخزونات داخل الامريكيه في اي حرب مع
الصين ربما تنفد خلال اسبوع واحد
لمتابعه هذه الاقالات والاستقالات الحاصله
في كاب مراس العربيه حذيفه عادل معنى اهلا
بك حذيفه ابرز التفاصيل حول هذه الاقالات
والاستقالات
ومن هي الاستقاله الاخيره في الساعات
الاخيره كان هناك ايضا استقالات جديده هل
او اقالات هل يمكن ان تعطينا تفاصيل
نعم تحياتي ميسون قام الرئيس ظلاميرسيليسي
قبل قليل بالتوقيع على قرار بايقاله اا
قاده الادارات العسكريه او حكام هذه
الولايات الخمسه ولايه كييف وولايه خرسون
وزباروجا وسومي ودينيبرا بيتروس اذا
القرار اصبح الان رسميا تمت اقالتهم بشكل
رسمي من قبل الرئيس الراديو ميرسي بعد ذلك
مباشره الرئيس
كوليبا وهو حاكم كيف العسكري الذي تم
اقالته من منصبه تم تعيينه
مكانه وهو نائم مدير مكتب الرئيس اذا عليك
سيكوبا يتم تحويله فقط من منصبه الى منصب
الى منصب ارفع في مكتب الرئيس السونابير
طبعا العقالات التي تمت ابرز الشخصيات هو
كريمه هو كذلك همم نائب وزير الدفاع
للخدمات اللوجستيه تحدث همم يعني بشكل
الامين في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيا الذي
قال ان هذه الاستقاله لنائب وزير الدفاعيه
تاتي
لعمليه يعني قال ان لتعزيز الثقه في وزاره
الدفاع وليس العكس انها لم تؤثر باي شكل
من الاشكال على عمليات الامدادات العسكريه
لوزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه طبعا ايضا همم
نائب المدعي العام الذي تمت اقالته وكذلك
تمت اقاله ثلاثه وزراء في وزاره البناء
التحتيه هذه الوزاره التي الان ت- تقود
ملفاتها كاعاده الاعمار وايضا اعاده همم
وكيف هي ردت فعل الشارع الاوكراني على هذه
الاقالات والاقالات بايجاز لو سمحت
نعم طبعا خلافه للاقالات الظاهره في وسائل
الاعلام هنالك اقاله او استقالات لعدد من
المسؤولين في هذه الوزارات هم ايضا من من
ضمن فريق العمل للوزراء المستقلين او
القاده المستقلين نعم الاعلام الاوكراني
يتحدث والمراقبين يتحدثون عن انه سيكون
هنالك اقالات واسعه واستقالات واسعه لبعض
الفرق والمستشارين الذين يعملون تحت امرك
او في بعض الملفات الهامه التي كان فيها
اما قضايا فساد او تصير في اداء المهام
بذلك نتوقع مزيد من الاستقالات والاقالات
شكرا لك من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
الرئيس الروسي لازم يتخذه خطوه كبيره خلال
الاسابيع القادمه
الى انه يخطط لتعبئه جديده تصل الى مئتين
الجندي الروسيه وفي السياق قال نائب رئيس
المجلس الامن الروسي
والاسلحه التي تضمن الاستمراريه في ارض
المعركه متهما الغربه
تقدر
هناك دائما حاجه للعوده لمعرفه ما يتم
انتاجه وكيف يتم انتاجه الجميع يشاهد ذلك
يدلون بشكل دوري ببيانات تشير الى انه ليس
لدينا هذا او ذاك او اننا نستطيع اطلاق
صواريخ مرتين ونصف فقط اريد ان اخيب ظنهم
لدينا ما يكفي من كل شيء منذ بدايه العام
الجاري تم تجهيز الامدادات بالاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه
نحن نتحدث عن الاف الوحدات
جامعه كبار الشخصيات الروس عبر الاتصال
الافتراضيه مشددا على ان روسيا ستنتج ما
يزيد عن ثلاث اضعاف من صواريخ الدفاع
الجوي شبيهه بنظام
في اخبار الساعه لدينا ايضا الخزانه
الامريكيه تفرض عقوبات على ثلاثه اشخاص من
حزب الله
[موسيقى]
نتابع مشاهدينا اخبار الساعه من لبنان
الان قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت عادت الى
الواجهه مجددا وبقوه
القاضي التحقيق في القضيه بتنحيته لم تؤخذ
على محمل الجلد حيث عاد القاضي طارق
البيطار في مهامه بعد اكثر من عام على
تجميدها من محكمه التمييز التي كانت تنظر
بدعوه
البيطار
استند في عودته على مبدا فصل السلطات الذي
يمنع محكمه التمييز النظر بقرار مجلس
الوزراء الذي احيلت عبره
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدين لعل الحدث الابرز بقرار العوده
للمحقق العدلي استعداده للادعائي على
مجموعه من الشخصيات السياسيه والامنيه
والقضائيه لتحقيق معها كمبدان عليهم حيث
افيد بان البيطار على المدير العام للامن
العام لواء عباس ابراهيم والمدير العام
صليبه الى جانب الدوله
بالاضافه الى رئيس الحكومه السابق حسن
دياب هو قائد الجيش السابق
[موسيقى]
بشكل مفاجئ قاضي التحقيق في انفجار مرفا
بيروت طارق بيطار يوجهوتهم لشخصيه سياسيه
ابرزها رئيس الوزراء السابق حسان دياب
بتهمه القتل على القصد الاحتمالي والمدعي
العام وثلاثه قوطات اخرين ويحددوا جلسات
الاستجوابهم في فبراير المقبل الدوله
ورده على قرار الادعاء اعلن المدعي العام
التمييزي في لبنان غسان عويدات المطلوب
للتحقيق اعلن رفضه القرار قاضي التحقيق
طارق البيطار باستجوابه بقضيه انفجار
بيروت وفي رساله طلعت عليها العربيه تحدى
عويدات المحقق العجيب انفجار المرفق بدعم
ان يده مكفوف عن التحقيق اي انه استبعد عن
هذا التحقيق
هو القاضي الذي كفت يده اكثر من 40 مره
عاد بعد غياب تخطى العام اشهر انتفاضته
القضائيه بوجه محاولات جماعيه لعرقلتي سير
العداله
طارق البيطار لنفسه استئناف التحقيقات
انفجار
غسان عويدات قرار استدعائه رسميا ضمن
رائحه من ثمانيه اشخاص على راسها ايضا
المدير العام للامن العام اللواء عباس
ابراهيم الذي بني على البيطار من استدعائه
سابقا
قرار اثلج قلوب اهالي الضحايا بعد ان بحث
حناجرهم مطالبين باستئناف التحقيقات
راي قانوني مخالف ممكن مراجعه المحاكم
المختصه مثل ما حتى هو باراره اشار لهذا
الموضوع انه اليوم المجلس العدلي عنده
الصلاحيه في ابطال او باعتبار ايا تحقيقات
غير
بموقعنا بموقع اما المساله الثانيه لليوم
عم تتحرك اكثر هي موقف النيابه العامه من
مساله خلقت السبيل بحقوقين بالملف اليوم
في خمس اخلاء سبيل لا يزيل اليوم مصير
تنفيذه او عدم تنفيذه مجهول
على اثرها ازدحمت ارجوك تقصر العدل بحسب
المعلومات بمفيدينا من المده عليهم وعلي
حسن خليل ويوسف
الوزراء المحسوبين على حزب الله هو حركتي
امل
ووسطنا خوف النيه وشارع شبيه بشارع السابع
من ايار ومخاطر قد يتعرض لها البيطار
تحدثت اوساطه قاضي التحقيق عن قيامه بما
يمليه عليه ضميره وان ما يخشى عليه فقط هو
مسار التحقيقات
اسامي كبيره
بالقضاء يتركب الشارع اللبناني ردود فعل
من استدعاهم القضاء في قضيه تسارعت
احداثها بعد تجميدها لاكثر من عام وصى
مطالبات دوليه بتحقيقا عادل وشفاف غن
ويتيم العربيه بيروت
لمتابعه هذه التطورات من بيروت نادر كسبان
النقيب المحامين اللبنانيين ينضم الينا
ستار اهلا بك معنا ما الذي [__] القاضي
طارق البيطار ان يستانف تحقيقه من جديد
وعمل دراسه انه في قرار صادر عن
المجلس العدل ايام الرئيس المرحوم في خير
الله رئيس الاول انه ما بيقدروا يطلبوا
اولاد
عضو للناس
بعد سنه ونص من الدراسه
انه بيقدر يرجع يحط يده على الملف
من جديد هل قادر قانونيه ان يوقفه من جديد
يعني تدخلات سياسيه طبعا ستستخدم وسائل
كثيره بالسياسه ولكن بالقانون هل هم
قادرون مره جديده على ايقافه
هلا هن عمليه
مثل المشي في انه بلش الكباش اول شيء
خليني اشرح لك شغله انا دايما كنت خاف على
الوضع الصحي بالبلد والوضع التربوي والوضع
المصرفي انا صرت خايف كمان على الوضع
القضائي ما بعرف مين اللي عم بحرك هالامور
بالبرد ااا الوضع القضائي يكون باللي عم
بيصير فيه لانه ولا مره انا الي محامي من
40 سنه ولا مره شهدت قصور العدل والقضاء
اللي عم تشهدوا هلا الكباش هذا اللي هو مش
شغله منيحه من شغله صحيه ابدا يعني
ايقاف هذا الكباش كما سميته حضرتك
هذا الكباش بعد لهلا مش عم نفهم شو سببه
يعني
قاضي المحقق العادي
بلش وانا انت قدام الكل وهلا اليوم انت
قدام اهلي صار مع انه ما بحبوا كثار
يسمعوا التحليله هيدا لانه هو صحيح انا
كنت بتمنى انه المحقق لعادل من الاساس من
الاساس انا انا اساسا
والتسعينات همم كنت بتمنى يرسم
وبيظهر انه هلا عم بتكملها
انا كان بدي انه وانا احد المصابين ما حدا
يقدر يزيد علي بقضايا بقضيه المعرفه وانا
رئيس مكتب الادعاء بالنيابه المحامين يعني
النقيب العامل انا كنت بتمنى انه المحقق
العدلي يصلوا استراتيجي معينه هي انه يحقق
بكل
تصل
حد بيقول يهمل ميت
همم
القاضي طارق البيطار اللي عمله له علاقه
بوفد القضاه الفرنسيه في بيروت
اذا بدك رايي الشخصي ما له علاقه بزياره
القضاه الاوروبيين لبيروت اذا رايه ما
قالوا عليه ابدا لانه والسال مره ملف
مختلف كليا
القاضي بيطار في الايام الاخيره
هل الوفد الفرنسي هو اللي اعطائها الفتوه
انه
يرجع همم مشان هيك هلا ممكن اذا لمحته او
حدا عم بلمح انه حدا اعطيه همم
اذا كان حدا همم
حدا عم يطلب منه حدا عم بيعطيها القوه انا
ما بدخل فياض وليكن همم هذا الموضوع نحنا
اليوم كنا عم نحلل كا ااا نعيبه اعلى مثنى
اه بيبقى محامين وهل انا بجمعه في 40
محامي انه القاضي بتعرف قعد سنه ونصف عم
يعتبر حاله انه اوكي همم مرفوعه يده عن
ملف شو اللي تغير هلا هل هل اجتهد همم
المجلس العدل اللي بيحكي عن قضاه المدرسه
عدله همم انه لا صار قادر يحط يده على
الملف ما بقدر اعطي رايي بس بقدر حلل
بشغله انه كيف معقول قاضي همم لا يطلب رده
طب اذا عم يحقق مثلا مع شقيقه يعني مع
اخوه من امه مش معروف انه كذا ما بيطلب
رده اذا لقطوا قاضي عم يرتشي ما بقدر اطلب
رده اذا فاذا لا يمكن لاحد انه يقول انه
القاضي لا يرد فانا اعطيك اذا بتعطيني
بعطيك مشروع انا مش هو مشروعي هو التالي
بيطلع التشريع بنزل سنه وبيرض فريقين اولا
الجهه الاولى انه لا ترف
ع يد عن الملف
قائد التحقيق بشكل عام
المحقق نقل الملف او مخاسه مثقودات هذه
بترضي فئه بيضل يكمل لو قدموها
الجهه الثانيه كمان بيرضيها وانا مقتنع
فيها بيصير في هيئه التهاميه يعني غرفه
اعلى منه مؤلفه من ثلاث اوضاض لانه كل
عمرنا ننتقد انه المجلس العدل المؤلف مثلا
من درج واحده لازم يكون درجتين وصلت
الفكره
شكرا لك من بيروت نادر كسبان النقيب
المحامي
يا اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبه على ثلاثه
اشخاص من حزب الله الاتهامهم بتسهيل تحويل
الاموال لحزب الله كما قالت وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه ان العقوبات فرضت على اشخاص
سهلوا تمويلا ميليشيا حزب الله عبر مراكز
استيرافه
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران تتلاشى بشكل
تدريجي بسبب الاساليب القمريه التي
يستخدمها النظام الايراني وفق تقديرا
لشبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه دعونا المتابعه
التفاصيل
اساليب قمعيه واعدامات متتاليه كانت هي
السلاح الابرز للنظام الايراني لمواجهه
الغضب الشعبي وبعد مرور اربعه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات وتنام الاستياء الشعبي بشكل
غير مسبوق تلا شازخم التظاهرات لكن الغضب
في اعلى مستوياته الاحكام القاسيه التي
كانت موجهه ضد المنشقين والاقليات العرقيه
والنساء على وجه التحديد
جعلت بقيه المتظاهرين الايرانيين يخشون من
مواجهه نفس المصير
سلسله الاعدامات لم تكن السبب الوحيد في
كلاش هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه فهناك عوامل
اخرى مثل قتل المتظاهرين بالرصاص
والاعتقالات الجماعيه والاعتداء الجسدي
والعنف الجنسي
كلها عوامل اساسيه كان لها دور في انخفاض
المعارضه من الشارع الايراني من جهه
وازدياد الاستياء الشعبي العام من جهه
اخرى
وتحديدا في المناطق الحدوديه التي تهيمن
عليها الاقليات والتي تحملت العب الاكبر
من قمع النظام
وكما يرى مراقبون فان معظم الاشخاص الذين
تزيد اعمارهم عن 25 عاما ابتعدوا عن
المظاهرات
بالاضافه الى الجيل الاكبر سنا منهم
والذين ضلوا الى حد كبير بعيدا عن الشوارع
التي تعمها الاحتجاجات وهو الامر الذي حرم
الحركه الاحتجاجيه الزخم اللازمه لاسقاط
النظام الايراني
وسطى توقعاتهم بان تعود هذه الانتفاضه
مجددا ضد النظام الايراني بسبب عدم قدرته
على معالجه المشاكل الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
بسبب العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه عليها
سلطان العيبان العربيه
[موسيقى]
تتطور والانتقادات بتثنيرا داخليه لاذعه
مصدرها اعضاء في حزبه الديمقراطيه
فالاستياء متى يخيم على افكاره عدد من
الديمقراطيين اتجاه القضيه بمجملها بدءا
من الاعلان عن اكتشاف الوثائق مرورا طبعا
للتصريحات الصادره من البيت الابيض بشانها
ووصولا الى العثور على وثائق جديده
الديمقراطيه جومانجل في عاليه في مقابله
مع شبكه تي ان ان قال ان على بيض ان يشعر
بالكثير من الندم على طريقه التعاطي مع
الوثائق السريه فيما اكد جون روبن نائب
مساعد وزير الخارجيه في اداره الرئيس
السابق باراك اوباما ان سبب هذه
الانتقادات الديمقراطيه هو من عدم انتهاء
الازمه بعد في المقابل السنه تؤديمقراطيه
والصديق بعيد عن المقارنه
حاول الدفاع عنه بقوله ان اكتشافه اوراق
جديده في منزل بايضا في حاضر يشتت انتباه
الامريكيين عن قضايا اهلا بكثير وان قضيه
وثائقي السريه تختلف بشكل جذري عن وثائق
مرغو مرجعا السبب الى ان عمليه البحث عنها
جاءت بطلب من البيت الابيض على عكس
الوثائق التي احتفظ بها الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ورفض تسليمها
اذا قضيه هذه الوثائق جعلت الديمقراطيه
يراقبون تفاعلاتها بحذر والسبب الخوف من
ان تنعكس بداياتها على الحزب بشكل عام
وبيض بشكل خاص ففي كل مره يظن الحزب ان
الموضوع وصل الى نهايته تظهر اوراق جديده
الى العالم وتتاهب القيادات الديمقراطيه
مجددا لاحتواء الاسماء لكن ما يجمع عليه
الديمقراطيين رغم هذه الانتقادات هو رفدهم
الواضح لاي مقارنه بين وثائق ترامب وفيما
يامل الحزب الديمقراطي انت تتلاشى الازمه
قريبا كي يتمكن ايضا من الاعلام الرسميا
عن ترشحه الى الرئاسه اظهر استطلاعهم
للراي لشبكه اي بي سي يخالف امالهم حيث
اظهر ان 34% من الامريكيين فقط يظنون
تعامل مع الوثائق بشكل مناسب بعد نهايه
عهد كان ابراهيم رئيس مقابله 64% يرون انه
تصرف بشكل غير مسؤول
[موسيقى]
من بعيد
حيث اكتشف محامي نائب الرئيس السابق حوالي
12 وثيقه تم تصنيفه على انها السريه في
منزل تنس الاسبوع الماضي وقام بتحويل هذه
السجلات السريه الى مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي وفقا لمصادر متعدده
وقالت المصادر اكتشف الوثائق السريه في
منزل تنس جديد في ولايه انديانا في عقاب
الكشف عن مواد سريه تم اكتشافها في المكتب
الخاص للرئيس
ومقري اقامته
من البيت الابيض تنضم اليه مناسبه العربيه
ناديه بلبيسي ناديه اهلا بك معنا ماذا
لدينا من تطورات جديده حول هذه الوثائق
وهذه الازمه حقيقه
البيت الابيض ميسون يحتفظ بنفس التعبير
منذ اكتشاف هذه الوثائق بالنسبه للرئيس
فايدل واكتشاف وثائق جديده لنائب رئيس
مايكلز ويقول بان الامر قيد التحقيق
وبالتالي لا يستطيع البيت الابيض ان يتدخل
سياسيا
ويحول كل اسئله الصحفيين التي تحاصر كريم
جون بير منذ اسابيع الى وزاره العدل لكن
الكشف اليوم عن وثائق في منزل مايك برنس
الابيض
قبل الانتخابات النصفيه في الكونجرس لكن
الان المشكله الاكبر بالنسبه للجميع ليس
البيت الابيض ولا ايضا الجمهوريين والرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب رغم انه هناك اسرار
بانه لا مقارنه بين ترامب وبين وفينس لان
الخيران عندما اكتش وهذه الوثائق ابلغ
وزاره العدل وابلغ سجل المحفوظات الوطنيه
بينما ترامب كان لديه المئات من هذه
الوثائق واحتفظ بها
واضطرت همم
الاف بي اي الى مداهمه بيته لكن الان
المشكله الاكبر هي كيف يمكن حمايه هذه
الوثائق السريه يعني هدم اعلن عنه ربما
سنكتشف بعد ذلك بان هناك حتى سنه طرز او
كونجرسمن او من غيرهم الذي نترشحوا او
خدمه في البيت الابيض او كانوا في منطقه
في مركز حساس احتفظوا بهذه الوثائق هل
هناك من تشريعات جديده يفكرون فيها مثلا
او اليه معينه لحمايه هذه الوثائق هل بدا
الحديث عن حمايه هذه الوثائق وكيفيتها
هذا هو السؤال الذي وجه الى كريم وطبعا
احلتنا الى وزاره العدل كما هو معتاد من
اجابتها لكن بالفعل على فكره هو قرار
تنفيذي يمكن للرئيس ان يتخذوا ويقول بانه
مجرد بان يترك البيت الابيض او خلال وجوده
في اخر ايام وقبل ان تكون فتره التسليم
لرئيس اخر او لنائب رئيس اخر على ربما سجل
المحفوظات ان يقرر هذه الوثائق كيف يمكن
تسليم ولكن المشكله هي بعمليه تعريف هذه
الوثائق الرئيس هو الذي يقرر اذا كانت
سريه او لا ومن هنا ربما حاول الرئيس
ترامب ان يبتعد نوعا ما عن الاتهامات
ويقول انا نزعت السريه يعني هذه الوثائق
لكنه قام بذلك بعد بعد ان ترك البيت
الابيض اذا الموضوع
قانونيا هناك الكثير من السجاد حاولوا لكن
الكشف عن هذه الوثائق سيؤثر اكيد على
مصداقيه البيت الابيض سيؤثر على مصداقيه
المرشحين لنذاكر بان رئيس سبايدر مان عن
الترشح ومن هنا اعتراض الديمقراطيه عليه
لانه يعتبر المثل الاعلى هو الذي انتقد
ترامب والان يقوم بنفس رغم انه طبعا ياكل
البيت الابيض بانه لا يجب ان يقارن لكن
ايضا [__] بينس هناك همم
نيه بالترشح للرئاسه وايضا دونالد ترامب
كل هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين اعلنوا حتى الان
بانهم يريدون ان يترشحوا لانتخابات 20 24
وجدت وثائق سريه في بيوتهم وفي منازلهم
عندما خدموا او عندما كان كما همم ذكرنا
سابقا بايضا كان سنتر في مجلس الشيوخ او
عندما كان نائب الرئيس لكن يعني اكيد
ديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
بس بالظبط شكرا لكم
من البيت الابيض مراسله العربيه ناديه
بلبيسي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنطلع بعد قليل في ظاهره
جويه نادره الثلوج تغطي ولايه بشار
الجزائر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم رياح العواصف التي يواجهها عملاق
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر لم تعد داخليه
مصدرها هذه المره ليس مدير التنفيذيه دعوه
قضائيه رفعتها شركات عقاريه عده ضد الشركه
السبب هو التخلف عن سداد الايجاري
المكاتبها في لندن برنسيسكو لكن العاصمه
لندن رفعت شركه كرانسليت المسؤوله عن
اداره العقارات التابعه للتاج الملكي دعوى
تطالب فيها تويتر بسداد الايجار المتاخر
لمقرها الرئيسي ووسط العاصمه اما في سان
فرانسيسكو الامريكيه رفعت شركه عقاريه
دعوه مماثله على تويتر لدخلوا فيها عن دفع
ايجار مكاتبها الرئيسيه لشهرين ديسمبر
ويناير حيث تخلف التوتر بحسب الدعوه عن
دفئ اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين دولار اجارا
لشهر ديسمبر الماضي ومبلغ يزيد عن ثلاثه
ملايين دولار ايضا ايجارا المستحقا لشهر
يناير لكن تويتر لن تتخلف فقط عن دفع
الايجار
خلفت عن دفع المبالغ مستحقه عن ايجار
رحلات طيران خاصه ايضا
[موسيقى]
شركه تويتر تواجه دعوى قضائيه من قبل شركه
كراون العقاريه التابعه للعائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بسبب تخلفها عن دفع الايجار
المستحق لمقر عملها السابق في هذا المبنى
هنا في بيكاديمي في وسط لندن هذه الدعوه
القضائيه ليست الاولى من نوعها يعني طبعا
شركه تويتر تواجه اربع دعاوي على الاقل في
الولايات المتحده حول المشكله ذاتها وهي
دافع ايجار مكاتب تويتر طبعا هذه الدعوه
تاتي بعد انفصل الماسك نصف القوه العامله
للشركه بهدف خفض التكاليف وهو ما دفع
الشركه بالفعل الى همم يعني ترك هذا المقر
همم فهذا المبنى هو واحد من بين المئات من
المباني التي تملكها شركه كراون العقاريه
وهي اكبر ملاك للاراضي هنا في بريطانيا
تولد ارباحا للخزينه البريطانيه يعود
حوالي 15% منها الى العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي
العربيه
في الجزائر في ظاهره جويه نادره شهدت
ولايه بشار الجزائريه صباح الثلاثاء
تساقطا كثيفا للثلوج خاصه في منطقه بني
ونيف التي تساقطت فيها الثلوج اخر مره عام
2012 عندما غطت الثلوج الكثبان الرمليه
والشوارع في مشهد طبيعيه نادر في هذه
المنطقه الصحراويه بعد الموجه البرد التي
ساحت الولايه
ذكر المدير العام منظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس اذانوم ان اعلن حاله الطوارئ الصحيه
لمواجهه كورونا قبل ثلاث سنوات كانت
الاعلى من ناحيه التاهب واعدفه المدير
العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه ان هناك حاله
من القلق ايذاء الوضع الصحيح العديد من
البلدان وارتفاع عدد الوفيات جراء تفشي
كروما
نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
دبابات في طريق هذه اوكرانيا بعد حل
الخلاف بين واشنطن وبرلين والكريم يتوعد
هو
قاد التحقيق في انفجار ما الفرق بيروت
يحرك المياه الراكده ويوجه اتهامه للمداعي
العام وثلاثه قضاضات
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكيه في
منزل مايكل
اشكر لكم فيفا المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]